有那個三段式的應對
阻止說明辦法
那就先看阻止
看課文喔
我直接唸他
阻止包含三要素
那個三個要素很重要
如果你手上有螢光筆
我們準備一下螢光筆
數字1
發文目的期望把它塗一塗
是重點我要放慢喔
數字2
內容我們先不看找到數字2
標題2
題文災要把它塗一塗
第三
期望語把它塗一塗
所以我們三個標題要塗一下喔
好
我來看一下怎麼講它比較好咧
這查掉
我寫音版書
不然我就一直用念齁也不知道
我就不確定你們看到重點
好這個不用操音就是我剛剛那裡塗螢光筆的三個標題
阻止三個東西做斟酌
我們就講了
好裡面其實我覺得最容易產生
共鳴跟共識的是期望語
因為我們上次上次上次有提到
阻止結束要期望語
為了讓你增加你熟悉
我們翻一下來
往前翻我陪你翻一下
喚醒你的記憶
你把往前翻翻到11頁這個地方
我們先不急往前翻
翻到11頁
11齁
11頁面中間可以看到常見期望語
上行平行下行還記得吧
對啊上次有提到
阻止結束我們希望對方看公文
請見合
我們希望對方辦理
請查照
用一定的官方文字去寫期望語
所以3今日沒有問題
阻止結束我們要請期望語
所以這個就今天不多說
我們今天要說的就剩什麼
目的跟宅要
我直接來齁
好 三解決
1跟2裡面哪個最重要
以目的為首要
阻止這一段寫作的生命力
最大的重點在於
去提示你發公文的主要目的
就你發公文給對方
一般人是希望對方知道某個事情
或做某個事情就抓目的
我希望你了解的是什麼東西
把你發文的最大目的寫到住這個地方
那摘要是幹嘛?
摘要大概講這不得性
所謂的摘要是
題目太囉嗦
有些提問會這樣子
囉囉嗦嗦的案情陳述一堆
然後這裡再跟你說
請你用行政院的立場發公文給立法院
請立法院做什麼東西
通常請立法院做什麼東西
換個顏色喔
這個區塊
行政院發函給立法院請他做什麼
才是行政院發函的主要目的
前面他只可能把
案情的因果關係稍微帶一下
案情的因果關係一般是不寫在阻止
是寫在說明
還記得吧
阻止說明辦法 阻止寫目的
你說明段
才有餘裕去把案情說得更清楚
可是反推
你如果在阻止段
把冗藏的案情也把它寫到阻止
那對方看完阻止就已經了解案情了
當他了解完全盤的案情的時候
你說明段就變得沒有東西可以寫
所以我們得到一個很重要的結論
你阻止越精簡的
只去帶到發文目的
不去聊案情的太多內容
是個好的現象
所以我們阻止是能摘要
盡量摘要
摘要出主要的目的
可以懂齁
好啊如果更白話的描述就是
冗長的案情描述
絕對不希望在阻止出現的理由在於
這樣會害得你在說明段沒有東西可以說
會變成阻止跟說明內容重疊度太高
好就這樣
那我們就看考題了
所以目前你剛銀光筆圖過的1 2 3解決
我們就看範例題
範例題這裡有點長
一樣也是不要急
時間先空白留給你
你先讀一下內容
什麼近年來外交部如何的
好你先把範例1的考題看一下
順便講點提示
看得有時候去抓
誰給誰
因為你要抓目的的前提是先抓發文機關跟射文機關
誰發功能給誰做什麼
主要目的慢慢抓
不急
第一題通了
後面會比較好銜接
先等你
那我再強調重點喔
你稍微在讀的時候你要很用力去抓一個關鍵
誰給誰做什麼
尤其是做什麼
抓一下
好了嗎
好
我陪你念
念的時候我們一樣手上來自筆
看有沒有重點
來我從頭讀
近年來
外交部推動簽署打工度假
鼓勵30歲以下青年走向國際
以度假為前提
藉由打工賺取旅費
可以拓展視野
你看
目前練到這裡刪很多
你有看到做什麼事嗎
沒有 都在說以前他做了什麼打工什麼
沒有看到目的
好 我們再來
體驗異國
培養自我能力
重點來囉
行政院制外交部
好 如果你有比我們圈誰給誰
我們把行政院圈起來
給誰 外交部
好 兩個機關把他圈起來
所以行政院給外交部
他說什麼
青年到國外打工人生安全很重要
因會同 哎唷 會同圈喔
會同是個動作對不對
好 我們先圈齁 再去抓重點
會同好 教育部勞工委員會若干機關
提供完再把提供圈起來
再把加強宣導圈起來
如果愛打工青年有疾難救助
掌握時效 盡速提供協助
我們再把協助圈起來
節慢一點
節一下我們剛剛圈的東西
我故意圈那幾個動詞
你要找人會同
然後你要加強宣導
然後你要給他協助
那一圈的動詞
算是誰的行政院給外交部嗎
好我們直接拉重點了
來美
所以行政院發工給外交部的主要目的是跟他說外交很重要
還是
跟他去談剛剛圈的重點
對
整個行政院最大的目的根本就跟他說
請你要會同請你要提供請你要協助
所以題為那下半段這個地方我們圈的那些文字那幾句
才是行政院發工給外交部
的首要目的
至於前面提到
什麼近年來的智力推動打工度假協定
根本不是行政院主要目的
而是案情的前因後果
所以就不必把它寫到阻止
這樣OK
好
如果還不OK也不用擔心
我有寫理答
你可以看到右邊23頁上方
有個理答
好理答我給你15秒吧
你大概看一下理答
好你看你答的時候可以發現
題文的前半段他有寫任何文字嗎
幾乎不碰觸對不對
什麼近年來他連寫都沒有寫完全不去碰觸他
好
所以透過你答應該更懂我的意思嘛
所以我們已經拉回這裡
盡量的把非必要資訊摘要去掉
我們要摘選出
首要的目的
然後首要的目的通常關係到前面什麼條件
誰給誰
所以我都給自己學生建議是
當你看到誰給誰
這個資訊一出現之後
後面的文字你的發條就要調進
要很快圈動詞
做什麼去把它找出來
因為找出來那幾句
你幾乎都是照抄寫到你竹子段
所以到此為止有提問問題
竹子段的寫作
是開放性的讓你聯想
開放
還是封閉性的讓你尋找
對封閉
但是封在裡面
讓你去找到對的把它圈起來
我們再聊另外一個話題
也就是
我們在改老師在改竹子的時候改什麼
直接講喔
改三八的人
哪個人三八囉嗦雞婆
寫什麼近年來推動什麼東西
哪個人就扣分
哪個人比較經典提到
你要會同你要宣導你要救助
我們就把他打勾
所以竹子有時候常講
他沒有加分的空間因為幾乎每個人都寫對但他有扣分沒有加分因為你都照抄怎麼加但他有扣分的空間 就是你如果三八一點東抄一句 西抄錯 寫太多 冗長
他反而被扣分 所以如果你要俗語講就是
不要把三八多餘的東西抄進去 我們精簡
因為公交計劃人家在辦事 你能不能囉嗦說 確實不對啦
好 我們再看範例二
23頁 範例二 好 一樣不吵你
你把範例二自己讀一下
先看先看不急
不要亂掉節奏喔
我還是再唸一次
我們盡量去找那一句
誰給誰
做什麼
下面有你答
你想自己去解讀都可以
就是好
你想看題目看不到
想再看你答也可以
有點長喔
先等你幾秒鐘
好我覺得應該是差不多
因為題目實在太長
我不想浪費上課時間念
待會兒幫你拉焦點
來
我覺得最大的焦點
題文應該倒數第二行
我們找到題目的倒數第二行
的右邊
國立台灣文學館特分函
就國立台灣文學館發函
給某市的國中跟國小
唉唷
所以文學館發函給學校誰給誰
我們看後面做什麼
呼籲他們主團是該館參加
那主要目的對不對
所以文學館發函給學校
呼籲你們可以來參加
是文學館發函的
首要目的
希望你可以來參加我的展覽
所以是主要目的
所以
題目前面一大堆提到什麼
他提到什麼
105年什麼兒童文學那些好
參展的時間啦然後裡面的作品的定義啦什麼專人導覽
那些要不要寫到阻止段千萬不要
我們把摘要掉所以融場的案情
我們不存在阻止
所以就這個案
就這個案例而言
是歡迎你可以來參加我們就寫這個就好
你說老師
前面印這麼多什麼什麼一堆的怎麼辦
沒怎麼辦
前面印這麼多什麼
展覽的資訊
想你知道是哪一段可以利用發揮
就說明了
所以你看多清楚
多寫一下
這樣你不用抄喔
竹子說
呼籲你們底下的學校可以來參加我們展覽對吧
然後我們再說
1本展覽時間從哪裡開始
2兒童文學作品是什麼
那不就好
資訊分配的很棒
可是你把這種東西全部抄在
你想像這個東西如果全抄在竹子
說明等於逼自己去死
就沒有東西可以寫
就不應該這麼做了
好
乾淨俐落嘛
就太容易吸收
我們再看范栗三
范栗三是有些題目是簡單到讓你沒有摘要空間
我們剛才兩題是很多還蠻清楚的
這應該是分到說明寫
有些事
完全連載藥都沒有載藥空間
你要花幾秒鐘把體溫看完
加強好各項傳染病
如果病人沒有檢驗者
然後依什麼規定
趕快交給主管機關
治理行間他有提到疫情從哪裡開始
疫情從哪裡結束怎樣
都沒有
他批的地就是
加強做什麼什麼什麼東西
所以
並沒有太冗長的案情陳述
所以你直接看下面的你答
他在主子第一句怎麼寫
請加強校園內如何的
算不算抄題目的第一句
算了
因為這題目乾淨俐落到
並沒有對案情融場的描述
好啦可以所以主子其實偏簡單
好那就把往後
還有放一題好
範例式也是題目
讓我們沒有摘要空間
你一樣把題文看一看
行政委給交通部持續加強載客船舶救生怎麼樣
你直接看你答的P頭DG也是
持續加強
對吧
你看
他題目寫過程有提到最近船難傳出很多
最近民眾傷亡很多所以你要加強什麼
都沒有
所以事前後果他沒有提到
只是說加強什麼東西
那當然就造型
所以在竹子的時候
這種提型竹子就非常好發揮
我問個小問題
把剛那句放大
像這種提型
竹子段
就非常好寫
我還有講一句難聽話
像這種提型
哪一段就很難寫
像這種提型竹子段好寫
但
說明段
就會比較難一點點
因為他完全沒有幫你把案情做說明
在說明的時候你就要發揮想像力去解讀
因爲什麼事
才會導致他發這個公文
所以其實考這種題目應該說的
考這種題目出題者
主要就是為了改你
寫說明的能力
你在說明段就要好好發揮
好
所以我們得到一個結論
當案情如果很長
哇 肉肉等
十幾行
案情很長的時候
我們是哪裡比較難寫
阻止 因為你看看得很累
但反推
案情很長的題目
說明段就超級好寫
反正都縮了嘛
但案情如果
很短 2 3行 30行
可能初步看竹子很簡單 但寫說明就會比較累
所以其實不同題型有帶來不同優劣的
好 那就可以懂來 但往下
二四頁它還有個特別案例
特別案例旁邊有印四個字
叫承辦實現 蠻重要的一個小細節
所以如果你有螢光筆或建議
那螢光筆
把那承辦實現四個字塗一塗
承辦實現
圖齁
好圖完這我直接講
寫公文的一個小小規定
這個規定我就直接談它來
規定什麼
手冊裡面的規定
規定就如以下他這麼說
當在承辦公務的時候
發文機關
提出某個
特定的承辦實現
發文者
提出某個特定的承辦實現
諸如我希望你8月8號之前
9月9號之前
五週之內
就是時間
承辦人提出某一個承辦實現
該實現
要在諸子段出現
也就是
你特別提出希望對方在某個時間壓力之內把他寫出來
那個時間
照規定規定
你要在諸子段寫出來
如果你諸子段忘記寫了
你想說
那我說明一段補寫可不可以
不行
就是算是個寫作商的瑕疵
所以阻止有一個小小的地雷啦
就是你看歸看
你還有更細的能力去找到
去發現他有沒有包含
承辦事件在裡面
如果有你要更細膩的去處理他
有放浪一題讓你去揣摩
好我幫你一念
某線給底下鄉鎮施工所
傳統市場改良購物環境
什麼行銷手法
有看到三個月吧
我們把它畫起來好不好
其實就是攤商的管理問題
但不是重點 重點是給對方三個月
按照我們剛剛的說法 三個月一定要出現哪一段
阻止 所以看下面你答
積極輔導 什麼固有人情侶
於三個月內 那三個月就不能把它刪掉
好 各位們眼睛拉回這裡喔
過度冗藏的案情 我們把它刪掉 摘要掉 刪除掉
但那些過度冗藏的案情裡面
如果不小心有存在 承辦實現
大哥 你不要把它刪掉 你要保留它
雖然是個小小地雷
要小心
我們才會吐螢光色
所以它不難
就是怕忘
現在講
你說 後來我也要啦
這真是會了
可是問題是考試當天
如果真的不小心三個月忘記抄
可能就是
扣分的地方
要小心
來
那我們竹子就解決喔
複習是
發發宿命不剛剛解決嘛
內容三段式不就主子說明辦法
主子可以寫的不就三點
我們把不要資訊刪掉多於刪掉
盡量找出首要的目的
就可以去抄題目
因為題目會給嘛 首要目的
太
冗長不寫它
可是我們把冗長刪掉的過程
特別要小心什麼時間
如果承辦實現
不要刪掉
記得結束的時候
我們一定要把它塞個什麼魚
期望魚
請查照辦理
請查照
請建合
請合適
合其單純好那麼阻止就結束掉我們往下學說明所以你看總共有三段是
主旨這麼輕快的結束掉
剩兩個說明跟辦法
甚至有些考題近年很流行
不用寫辦法斷
所以大概今天的重點
最後一個可能跟考試比較密切相關的說明
好那其實說明不難我們就開始來看
寫作原則有看到嗎
標題7
好我唸囉
旨在說明或者解釋發公文的理由跟原因
就是我們剛一在聊到的前因後果嘛
你說明主要在表達你發公文的原因跟理由前因後果
基本上
你不用畫任何重點就是陳述案件
阻止是為了陳述目的
說明是為了說明案件
很清楚一標題說明就講清楚
好
然後括號二他有提到
說明段中不要有辦法
這個也合理就是不要跌床假污
我們剛剛用力講就是
竹子段裡面不要說明案情
因為你要留給說明說
現在聊的是
說明段中不要提到辦法
因為你說明寫的辦法
下面如果辦法
那又不是跌床假污
所以各段寫各段的資訊
這超級合理
所以就怕你說明提到辦法
好
那一跟二解決那我們就聊
寫說技巧
來
大家提到
已考場
除非案情很特殊
不然一般而言說明段通常寫兩項
好我們把那兩項圈起來 兩項是常見
不代表一定啦
你當然有時候需要到三項 四項我都有看過
但常見是分配兩項比較常見
我們寫一下好來 我們剛剛圈兩項
你在兩項上面幫我加一些文字
常見
好
兩項常見解決
那兩項的寫法下面有印
它括號1跟2
第一個是原因
旁邊括號文字我順便念齁
寫出案件發生的原因
第二個影響性
發生的原因起因嘛
然後後面的後果
基本上我幫你寫文字
常見我們寫兩項
兩項第一個邏輯是原因
然後第二個他說什麼
影響性 影響性基本上是什麼
注意聽喔
其實就是我們平常很熟悉的什麼
因果關係
說明往往常見嘛
要寫兩項
我們一會寫齁
事情的起因
邏輯因跟他可能導致的後果
所以你看他的邏輯是超級清楚喔
你看阻止說
請幫我做某些事情
因為日前怎麼樣
發生了什麼東西
所以你要積極的面對它
所以如果需要辦法下面不是有辦法嗎
就提出承辦策略
所以你要搞定1搞定2搞定3
我再走一次喔
請你幫我解決這個東西主要目的
因為發生了什麼
它會很嚴重
所以你可能要做某些作為
它才順著往下出現辦法
如此而已
所以常見說明的出發點
因跟果
好 所以如果你願意寫拿一支筆
你在原因旁邊把寫因
影響性旁邊把寫果
我覺得這樣對你理解更方便
就學到經驗嘛
好老師跟我說
我們在說明段是為了把
案情做陳述
陳述什麼
陳述他的因跟果
好
會給你一些範例
如果你聽懂我們就看右邊的範例題
範例照例我們節奏放慢
你先慢慢讀考題
下面也都有擬答兩項
你想看都可以看
這個都因為第一次看說明嘛
我們都不要急
第一題慢慢來
你先看題目
再看他擬答他的邏輯
我是覺得
像這種偏簡單的東西
有時候讀完
不太需要老師
我陪你念
教育局給地方上的學校
那應該嚇醒
加長學生中錯預防通報
落實教育均等
所以他就是基本上中錯生的案件
像這個題目簡略
我們剛剛題目簡略
就是我們寫說明會比較累
要自己去編因果關係
你看怎麼編
統計顯示
新年度以來中錯的比例不減反徵
算不算原因啦
我覺得算
教育局發函給學校跟他說幫我搞定中錯生
一定是因為中錯生變
多
異於往常 因為如果是
中錯生 如果開學到現在
整個室內
都沒有人中錯
白癡才發這個函
隆伯中錯生 那你發個函說請你搞定中錯生是咻笑
一定中錯生異常很多
教育局才無聊發這個函
我們再看第二點
小學是教育基礎 他們載學會影響日後的對美 如果這樣中錯掉影響日後更長遠的發展
所以後果沒
最近實在太多人中錯
搞不定的話會嚴重影響孩子的學習
所以你看如果有辦法
所以你要做這個做這個去做預防
超級合理
因根果
不過再聊一下
像這種超級合理
來自於
也不是超級
來自於要有一定的社會觀察
也就是像這種題目我剛剛聊到
當題文偏簡單的時候
整個作答壓力
就是壓在說明段
他靠
一定的社會觀察跟想像力
就是你要懂一點點
事情可能的起因跟後果
也就是以這一題而言
如果考生對中錯生完全沒有接觸
他寫說明段就會很容易被扣分
所以像這種題型作答的增結點
就在於說明段
OK齁
好我們再看範例二
一樣給你先讀喔還是不要急
因為畢竟這種東西有點想像力
他題文太短
那你得去想像起因可能是什麼
後果可能是什麼
好你都先讀
慢慢讀喔 我給你時間
好 我來念
可以吧 來
教一部給好全國各級學校
加強智慧財產的宣導避免侵權
也是
這應該是阻止好寫啦 加強好
智慧財產權
開始看他你打來
二來
旅傳學生智慧財產權概念不正清楚
因書籍產生侵權很合理的原因吧
他教育部發函
教育部給學校跟學校說
去落實智慧財產權一定是因為什麼
學生亂印美
如果從而到以學校都沒有人印智慧財產權大家各安其分
神經病才發的函
好起因
二
尊重智慧財產權是現在公民素養
所以培養他 增進他長期以來認知
是學校的重要 也有重要性
他提到什麼
國際趨勢跟基本
對 那是他的重要性
學生亂印
那我跟你說
這位財產點是全球性關注的東西
你不搞我們其實
教學觀感上會很糟
整個後果在這地方
那是全球一致的趨勢
教育單位得落實於他
靠想像力把它寫出來
所以我們再走一次喔
這題難在於
他只給一個輕鬆的一句話
智慧財產權 學校啊
你搞定智慧財產權的情有可能是什麼
學人亂搞
然後再去談智慧財產權的重要性在於什麼
那是個趨勢 那是個公民素養
很合理的 靠想像力帶出一跟二
或這麼說 寫這種題目就是要想像力
但想像力還是要一點線索
不然你會亂噴 導致那個作答沒有邏輯
那最好的邏輯基本上 就是因跟果
OK齁
所以之後如果再遇到題目很短
那真的有一些壓力
也不知道怎麼寫出一跟二
記得就不要有壓力 冷靜
先去反推
起因可能是什麼
再去搞定
他對整個
觀感
重要性後果是什麼
應該還是可以寫出來的
好
如果
真的寫不出來
就同學問說老師
聽了我怕很難
如果你是覺得這種東西可能很難
寫不出來送給好消息
像這種簡短式的出題
就題文很短的這種初期模式
在我們國營跟港務的考試
很少看到
近年的趨勢都是給的超級多
我等會陪你看列視題
給都是很多
所以你剛剛如果覺得簡單你可以搞定
那是好事
你剛剛如果覺得很困難
怕你搞不定也是好事
因為他幾乎在近年
他是不出這種模式的
好啦所以無論如何
還是維持我們上課的調性
他就自身很簡單不用太害怕
好基本觀念搞定搞定打個信號寫作經驗延伸開始有一些小小一些就是會有一些普遍的東西那會延伸一些小個案小東西
就用信號來帶
寫作經驗延伸1
我來讀
他說什麼
若該公文有承辦來源
他括號甚至寫
由其他單位來函給本單位
則疑於說明第一項
好我們把第一項畫的確
等下我慢慢講你先畫
寫上該案的承辦依據
不知道你有沒有讀懂
我用我的白話解釋
也就是
他提到那個什麼
由其他單位來函給本單位
我直接講就是
我寫黑板好了
你不用抄
先看
也就是理解起來我覺得這種公文叫非自發心
公文就有種叫自發心就是
事情是我的權責範圍我覺得要做
我自己發起文書問長官問其他單位
好
我覺得是我要做
我覺得我要做的是主動發起文書那要自發
有些不是
就是我職權範圍的事
我可能忽略或沒有注意到
民眾先發現了來函檢舉
或長官先發現了
甚至來電喔
來電跟我說
或主管發現了
在會議裡面先提出來
然後後面會議結論叫我做
主管來電叫我做
民眾來韓叫我做
會議決議叫我做
無論如何起心動念都不是我主動要做
是別人叫我做
這叫非自發性
公務人員依法辦事的調性很清楚
如果不是我主動要做的
是他來電叫我做起因就是他來電
是他來韓叫我做起因就是他來韓
是會議決議叫我做起因就是這個會議
所以誰叫你做
你要全責要交代清楚
所以我們剛才用力去掛那個第一項
所以重新理解是
當該文屬於非自發性
有其他任何形式的來源叫你做
我們通常在第一項會把它講清楚
交代事情的起因
剛剛被我插掉了
來自於民眾來電
起因來自於長官如何的
好 這樣可以懂
所以有承辦來源嗎
這樣可以吸收啦
來源不是你有另外的承辦來源
好 可以懂
但我覺得我們看完範例
我覺得就沒有什麼好爭議的
你把題目讀一下
下面有範例題喔
好你先慢慢讀黑心食品
一樣不急你先慢慢讀
不要草率
下面有你的啊你都可以一併參考
有看他那你答說明第一項寫什麼嗎
我陪你念齁來
好
社會上黑心食品消費者恐慌
所以衛生署成
我們先用個小關鍵成時間
我們把成表示過去
好時間成我們先圈齁以前齁
給地方衛生局
他以前跟衛生局說什麼
請你趕快提出辦法好好執行
同時你要行文見負
我們上週叫見字等於我
好 怕忘再寫一次
行文見負那個見把它圈起來
我們在見底下加這個字
這裡見翻成我齁
好
所以以前跟你說你要提出處理辦法
同時行文回覆給我
那這時候地方是你齁
各縣市衛生局之富含
所以衛生局就要回覆給他
我用黑板表達一次來
衛生署
衛生署發函成過去喔
過去
發函給以跟以說黑心食品搞定
搞定完了行文見負
當然他發函給他有跟他說你要回覆給我
那時間一到你看題文的最後句
是你各縣市之父啊那我當然回覆啊
你當時來函叫我搞定
黑心食品
同時叫我回覆
今日我當然以這個立場好
橘色的比較小心喔
回覆給他 我們現在聊喔
他回覆給他的這一份公文裡面聊一下
這個公文他回覆給他嘛
這個公文算不算有依據來源
算
箭頭很清楚啊
你當時來函叫我做
我今日才會回函給你
那我們剛剛不提到
當非自發人 根本不是自發
也不是我要搞黑心
是你當時叫我搞黑心視頻
我今日才會回覆給你
所以符合我們剛剛的條件
第一項 寫上來源
你趕快看你答
依據什麼
我們拿一支筆
把那個均屬圈一下
因為在這樣一的描述裡面
只有均屬要聊一下他
後面
圈圈連圈圈字號
基本上虛擬嘛
就全部都照抄 也就是我聊個經驗
日後你遇到類似這種公文
對方來韓
今天你要回覆給他
你的第一項的寫法
你說明一將來寫法
就跟這個一模一樣
依據某某機關什麼時間
什麼函我來承辦
也就是你要修改的
只有你剛剛圈的那個地方
這裡因為是衛生署嘛
所以你用軍署
如果這樣是行政院
你當然會把它改成軍院
所以這裡可能會做一些變動
名稱問題的變動
但整體邏輯應該是沒問題
所以重新講一次
這是好東西喔
如果你以後在
閱讀題文的過程
抓到依據
喔 有依據
請你心裡嫌開心
因為你說沒依據就不用想太多
你就可以依題目去寫
依據什麼機關
什麼時間
什麼含叫辦理
他是相對性的好寫
不像有人剛剛寫原音
不是有剛剛不是音跟果
剛剛音也沒有到很難
但你還是要花時間去想像
這個就沒有想像的那麼累
但就是要有觀察的細節
如果你有觀察的細膩能力
你看到
你就不用這麼累
反推
如果有依據你沒有看到
你會很辛苦的編
更不專業
同時會讓自己更累而已
所以我覺得
有依據是個好消息
幫助你更快速的掌握
好所以他在打信號
寫作經驗延伸1基本上是第一個禮物對不對
好東西
避免我們寫原因寫太辛苦
我們再往下翻經驗2
好念齁
若該公文有復健
對吧我們剛剛聊到有些公文會有附件就參考資料
這移於說明段中
我們把說明段畫底線
說明段畫底線
我希望加點文字
好你在說明段上面加點文字你把它寫上幾個字
一般是在說明的最末項
因為說明有時候一項兩項三項四項
不論幾項
我們這個要學的東西它就擺在最後
好我持續念
說明的最末項
寫上簡算或者簡成圈圈復健一份
好很簡單也是我們剛剛聊到
如果你發現題目是要寫復健
然後復健的名稱
在說明段得出現
出現在哪裡
說明的最後一項
你看下面那個範例
我念
法國部給檢查機關查氣經濟犯罪
保障投資人
訂定了十大原則
請對方依照規定
好啊可以想像
那個十大原則可能隨涵附上讓對方去成敗
好
如果可以想像那個原則可能要當成復屆
你看這題說明你答
1那當然自己想像什麼犯罪增多
2是不是很輕鬆
減送
什麼十大原則一份
那可以很輕鬆的解決你說明的模像
說明這樣聊
如果我們在看考題的時候
發現這一題是有復健
復健是好事還是壞事
先講
就外行的人復健是壞事
他會說
煩死了又要抄這個鞋那個
他會覺得又是個障礙
又是另一個要花出心思去解決的
可是就成熟的做達者而言
在考試的時候
應該這麼說啦
在官場上復健真的很煩
因為要多做個處理
但在考場上
復健的真的是好事
他會讓你說明
有更多東西可以寫
同時展露你對公文的認知跟專業
同時你又可以寫長一點
觀感上比較好看一點
所以這是另一種小專業
如果你考試逮到這個專業
可以賣弄一下
也別說賣弄
應該確實是可以寫的
你就寫一下
增加你的加分可能
所以不聊多
如果附件記得要寫說明的墨像